welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
voss and house of the dragon is the game
of thrones prequel series based on
george rr martin's novel from 2018 fire
and blood and we have a new teaser for
this 10 episode series coming in spring
2022 on hbo max and even though new
rockstars has shifted to covering pretty
much everything marvel in the recent
years boy oh boy is it great to be back
talking thrones since this was a show i
started new rockstars videos with all
the way back in 2016 all the way to the
bitter bitter end but of the many
spin-offs that were announced this was
the one i was most excited for because
fire and blood is a great story and
based on everything i've seen so far
about this series the production design
the cast it's gonna be fantastic i'm
gonna react to this teaser do my best to
explain all the characters how they're
related to each other what the story is
gonna be all about explain how this all
connects to what we know from the song
of ice and fire timeline and what i'm
most looking forward to about this
series so let's take a look and hear we
how did they get the hbo title just
float there
looks like we're on dragonstone
okay interesting they call it the fall
of the throne it's like from their point
of view
okay otto hightower i'm guessing
there's the first
fire
okay
and blood
back to incest
oh the armor looks great
oh there's so much wait is that the
holy crap
oh it looks so much better
i love that they're going with an older
design of the throne
are they just pretending like the new
throne didn't happen and they're doing a
redesign or are they saying like it
changed i have so many questions i have
so many ideas i'm super excited for this
okay so just to give an overview of the
characters and how they're related we
got king viserys the first targaryen
he's one of the viseryses that daenerys
brother was named after he's technically
daenerys's great great great great great
great great great grandfather i think
that's eight greats basically 10
generations previous he's married to
allison hightower who ends up leading
one faction of the dance of the dragons
that's a targaryen civil war that this
series is going to show the events
leading up to the rivals to that faction
will be viserys's firstborn child
rhaenyra targaryen and her incestuous
relationship with matt smith playing
damon targaryen who is viserys younger
brother technically ronira's uncle
renera later goes on to lead to the
faction called the blacks so we got the
greens versus the blacks before hooking
up with damon rainier's first husband
was this other family that we're seeing
in this house velaryon they lead an
island called driftmark that's just to
the southwest of dragonstone the seed of
the house targaryen their sigil is the
seahorse they're led by lord corliss
velaryon known as the sea snake he's one
of the best seafarers of westeros his
son is lenore velaryon who spoiler
warning does end up dying early which
allows rainer to remarry to damon and
then everyone else kind of revolves
around this central cast but thanks to
hellofresh for sponsoring this video get
mouth-watering seasonal recipes and
fresh pre-measured ingredients delivered
right to your door with hellofresh
america's number one meal kit hellofresh
makes cooking at home fun easy and
affordable it's fall and hellofresh has
some great fall flavors mix and match in
the hellofresh market with sweets and
beverages like ready to bake pumpkin
cinnamon rolls and spiced lattes i have
come to really love cooking and i just
love how hello fresh helps you save time
and stress you can get some tasty
home-cooked food on the table in just 20
minutes with their quick and easy
options hellofresh has more 5 star
reviews than any other meal kit so you
know you'll be getting something
delicious in every delivery last night i
made a chicken sausage spaghetti
bolognese mama mia wasn't good i'm a big
boy making big boy food
pasta
so go to hellofresh.com and use the code
rockstars14
to get 14 free meals plus free shipping
so just kind of reacting to what we see
here looks like we see daemon in
dragonstone burying a torch going down
through the tunnels damon and rhaenyra
looking out on the water from the coast
of dragonstone we get this awesome shot
of the skull of baleria in the back
dread with all these candles in front of
him like a vigil i love that we're
seeing valerian this way because
remember in the game of thrones timeline
after robert baratheon sacked the iron
throne all of these skulls were
previously just kept in the red keep put
on display as a show of power to anyone
who might greet the targaryen king on
the throne but robert baratheon
hating the targaryens moved all of the
dragon skulls out of the red keep and
put them beneath it in the dungeons
which is where we saw an episode of game
of thrones but here they have all these
candles surrounding them as if they're
kind of these religious icons that the
targaryens still have this immense
respect for but it's also almost like a
stupid magic trick like they put these
candles in front of them as a way of
showing like these things can still
breathe fire generations after this the
dragons would go extinct and these
skeletons and skulls and displays would
really be all they have there's a
close-up shot of someone wearing the
hand of the kingpin this is actually
otto hightower who's alison's father he
ends up being a political rival to matt
smith as prince damon and we see briefly
the king who he serves king viserys the
first he's got his targaryen ring and
he's holding a specific sword this is an
important sword called blackfire this is
the original valyrian steel sword of
house targaryen that belonged to aegon
the conqueror who created this whole
dynasty and this sword was passed down
to each king thereafter but up until
what was called the blackfire rebellion
which would be about 60 years after
these events when the sword was lost and
again this guy is married to allison
hightower otto's daughter together they
have a bunch of kids the eldest of which
is aegon the second targaryen whom in
this dance dragon civil war the greens
want to carry on the line of succession
but a lot of this drama comes from the
fact that renera was passed over due to
the paternalistic laws of succession and
the way this all works and we're going
to be jumping around at different times
of reneara's life including seeing her
as a younger woman and we're going to
learn that she has a relationship with
sir harold westerling he's a member of
the king's guard who was tasked with
watching over and protecting her i love
all these shots of the candles being
blown out as a way of showing that the
power of house targaryen is really
starting to wane this is really the
beginning of the end of the family up
until this point their rule was
unquestioned but this is the first time
the family started to turn against each
other which led to the dance of dragons
and then a whole bunch of blackfyre
rebellions in the generations after that
which really eroded the power of the
family generation after generation until
the point where robert baratheon was
able to sack it and even then he was
only able to do that because the
lannisters turned against them last
minute we get a quick shot of this melee
between these awesomely armored soldiers
this one must be daemon targaryen
because you can tell from the sword that
he's holding this is the dark sister it
previously belonged to his father balon
targaryen this is the first time we've
seen targaryen armor in live action like
this they have this awesome dragon
winged helmet armor in this style was
described when rhaegar fought robert
baratheon but here they have this almost
spartan style armor just an interesting
way of showing how all this is taking
place 200 years earlier before the
events that we saw so it makes sense
that this would be more of a roman
aesthetic as opposed to the later
medieval styles that we saw in game of
thrones we see lord corliss in the house
of elerion greeting them at this banquet
the reason they have this blonde hair is
they have targaryen blood they are kind
of related with the targaryens
themselves you can see in the background
of this banquet that's the iron throne
there with the sigils of house targaryen
on the left house of valerian on the
right that's the seahorse i assume this
is a wedding banquet celebrating the
marriage of renera the daughter to
laynor valerion america does not last
long again so we're going to talk about
this dark-haired woman this is messeria
who's a woman from essos who became
damon's basically mistress of whispers
most trusted ally kind of like what
varys was for a lot of the monarchs and
then my favorite shot from this trailer
we see alice at hightower she's with the
red hair and she's wearing green right
so she leads the greens faction of the
civil war she is carrying this dagger
and you should recognize the stagger
this is the same valyrian steel dagger
that we saw throughout game of thrones
first is the cat's paw weapon that was
used to attack bran in winterfell that
we later learned at his whole backstory
with littlefinger and with tyrion it's
basically what littlefinger used to try
to frame tyrion but really it was
joffrey who ordered that hit and of
course was later given by bran to arya
arya used it to execute littlefinger and
then of course to kill the night king
but here they're saying this dagger was
the same one that was part of this very
interesting conflict between the
families so basically the backstory here
is allison had a few kids one of whom
was a ten-year-old named eamond and when
lenore died his father king viserys told
him that he could get a dragon egg
because he was the only one of his
siblings who not had his own dragon yet
so he snuck near the dragon and was
caught by his three-year-old nephew
joffrey who's part of the valerions and
he pushed joffrey into dragon poop and
then hijacked the dragon and went on a
joyride which led to this whole fight
with joffrey's older brothers and eamonn
basically insulted them by calling them
strong's essentially calling them
bastards and then joplin's older brother
lucerus was pissed off and then used a
dagger to cut out his right eye and then
alicent the mom of aemond was so pissed
off she demanded lucerus to lose an eye
as penance for that and it all came out
that eamonn called them strongs it was
this huge insult to the family basically
calling them illegitimate but king
viserys prevented his wife alison from
taking this penance it's very similar
thematically at least to the events in
the riverlands in the game of thrones
series the fight between joffrey and
arya that later led to the direwolf's
death a spat among children representing
this broader hatred between the sides of
the families it's kind of like that show
the slap i think everything in life is
like the show's a slap but the fact that
they are making it the same dagger that
was so important to game of thrones is
just kind of an interesting thing of
making this one dagger such a cursed
weapon that has been responsible for so
much bloodshed and the unraveling of the
political power of westeros but also
later something that saves westeros
against the night king anyway we get
some cool jousting shots they pass a
bunch of banners that might look
familiar i see how stark that might be
house bolton it's held at the tarlys it
looks like a writer for house charlie
fighting a writer of house cole that
looks like the nine black dots and then
lastly this epic shot of the iron throne
now in game of thrones it was for
production reasons a simpler throne but
just like a cool sword look to it but
really the design of the books is
supposed to be a big giant nasty nest of
swords that's really really tall takes a
bunch of steps to get up to it and with
this show it looks like they're kinda
meeting halfway between the two designs
you have the sword in the background but
this kind of nest of swords surrounding
it i don't know if they're gonna pretend
that the old design never happened i
think with that dagger they're pretty
intent on trying to link as much as they
can to the original hbo series so i
think instead what we might see are
these swords melted down or stripped
away from it to eventually evolve this
throne into the throne that we saw in
game of thrones also interesting to note
that the windows of the red keep do not
yet have the seven-pointed star of the
faith of the seven and that's because
this is long before baylor the blessed
basically built the sept in king's
landing and really established the faith
as the official religion baylor the
blessed would have been damon's grandson
but the last thing i noticed is this
great music from ramin jawadi who's
coming back to compose the series one of
the reasons i'm most excited for it they
have a vocal version of the fire and
blood house targaryen theme music
[Music]
i'm just most excited for this because
they're keeping a lot of the aesthetic
stuff that i loved about the game of
thrones series in this show some amazing
production design set design costuming
music while hopefully having a bit of a
narrative reset and because we're
further back in history we know how
everything ends so we can just kind of
take our time unfolding the narrative
and showing the political drama between
the characters as opposed to what we saw
in game of thrones where they were
trying to basically extrapolate from
what george rr martin intends to end the
books with while letting go of some of
the more interesting story lines and
just trying to rush the ending i'm
hoping we don't see that here there's no
rush take your time with it well once
this show comes to hbo max we're gonna
be covering that episode by episode
hopefully bringing back some after shows
it's gonna be an exciting time so if you
haven't already subscribe to new
rockstars for breakdowns of this and
everything that you love and you can
support us by checking out our merch
options at newrockstarsmerch.com i
assume we'll have some westeros inspired
designs you can follow me on instagram
and twitter ea bots follow and subscribe
to rockstars thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you